[Music]
hi
how are you guys doing welcome to a
combined version of just on psychology
and
end games so
i did a little segment on twitch on
sunday about
slippery dorsa and i showed two games
that
i should have lost or at least i was
worse and i kind of slipped away
so that kind of gave me the idea to show
a few more of those
so yeah it's kind of interesting
oh hi carter i see from portugal i was
in portugal in 2017. so
um without further
uh let's just jump into it so
the first game that i want to show you i
was playing black
against um well back then
in 2015. he was a kid shubin
uh curiel he was it was in jaguar
memorial and
saint petersburg and i was very close to
crossing 2 400 i was very close to
getting all my norms and titles back
then
i completed that by mid 2016.
yeah so this was a especially
interesting segments for me like that
whole period of 2015 hunting down norms
from going from double eim to wgm and
iem that was kind of like
um a little huge deal so
okay um so in this game
um i'm gonna give you a little bit of
spoiler i was
way worse like just thinking about it i
have no idea how i survived this
but my opponent was um he was a good
player i think he was maybe like
the 11 12 years old and he
had already 2100 almost 2200
and so i'm not the biggest sicilian
player but i gave it a good try
in 2015-16 and
it's just it doesn't feel like it's for
me
to be honest um so i'm trying so um
basically the theory the normal theory
is to take with the knights right
to get to that like neither positions
but um this guy uh
kyrie would like to well take with the
queen and there's nothing wrong with
that too
so i think i think this was actually a
famous game that's in 2015
uh karjakin had played or that was the
idea
so my idea was to actually um
somewhat replicate that game and uh
ultimately get that at five yeah i think
this was in world cup 2015
because when i was in saint peter's work
i remember that
i was following the world cup so yeah
like i'm kind of sure
it was um it was that
so yeah um so
in this position after castle cast on
knight c3
uh what do you guys think black should
try to do like
what do you think are some of the um
just ideas like what is your plan right
now
it would be nice to get some of your
ideas so i can just
well yeah basically what do you want to
do with this bishop
what do you want to do with your pawn
structure
what about this night
it would be nice to get some ideas but
if you guys
are still warming up that's perfectly
fine too
um i mean we don't really want to give
up three pawns right
e5 is uh possible e5 is possible but
then you're giving out the d5 square
bishop d7 is i think the the kind of
like the normal
way to go um
what else are there b6
b6 bishop b7 i think is another way to
go
um i kind of wanted to give this idea a
try to get the knights to e5
yeah thank you floyd to get the knight
to e5
and then try for f5 but i'm pretty sure
f5 here was a little premature like
i should have tried for something
a little bit more subtle maybe like
queen a5
or take on f3
yeah i think something like that would
be a little bit more
subtle than f5 f5 just felt like a
mistake
at the game my biggest problem was that
i was trying to
use the idea that karyukin used in this
game but i kind of um
didn't i wasn't patient enough to get to
that position
well happens right
so after f5 why do you think f5 is not a
good move
so basically what do you want to do with
white
oh um you kind of want to bring like
knight to g5
maybe but um yeah what do you think
happens if you do this knight exchange
like if you try to take knight takes e5
what then
my d5 is also poops knight d5 is also
possible but
so let's let's think a little bit more
about what f5 change about changes about
the position
so what what do you think about knight
e5 like after 95 what should i take it
back with
yep that is the game so
um nice e5 is the best move for white
and the thing is i can't really take it
with the knight because just
immediate f4 and
um as soon as i play like knight c6 then
e5 and the d6 pawn is in big big trouble
right so let's go
back
so after f5 take i kind of decided to
take it to the bishop to try my chances
there
and after f4 but i still have the same
problem if i play bishop g7 there's e5
again you move the queen
to a5 just lose the pawn i was trying to
just kind of um not get into this kind
of position so you can already see why
i'm calling it slippery huh because i'm
already in a bad position
so i made the um sad decision to take
on c3 it is bad because
just simply clean tanks and
now i basically have two choices i can
either try for check
or try taking right
um the bishop for two rooks is not a
good idea
the um sorry two pieces for a rook is
not a good idea
and also in this position uh taking
on c3 is i mean i think i thought taking
on c3 was my only chance
so what do you guys think between queen
b6 check or
taking on e4
do you have a favorite what's my
favorite sicilian
ice cream i like the sicilian pistachio
ice cream huh
it's a good one
um yeah taking an e4 is better honestly
i played queen b6 and i regretted it
pretty much the whole game
so the thing is if queen b6 bishop goes
to e3
then what do you want to do possibly
queen b4
clean b4 then this queen goes to c2 and
your queen is kind of trapped
because a3 is happening right it's kind
of getting
to be a little scary so let's go back
and i want to show you
why f takes e4 is the better oops
the better way
so taking on e4
the idea is you still want to give this
check but you are not really um
showing your hand so b4 with idea just
getting the bishop on the
like the mating style now we can just go
for e5
and maybe get the queen out the other
way or maybe even take knight stakes e5
i mean by like i'm not saying this is a
good position
i'm saying this is still better for
white but it feels like it's a little
bit
better like just compared to what
happened in the game
so um
yeah so let's go back here after
um queen takes c3 i gave this check
i did this queen before and i took over
here
this already feels pretty bad right can
someone tell me
why this is a like the actual move or
the actual line of why this is a bad
idea
i'm actually curious to know what is his
um my
back then opponents rating now i'm going
to check that out real quick
i kind of wanted to do that before the
game before i before the class
um he can take e4
that's not the idea that's not the one
that's not the why
uh why this is a bad move yes thank you
thank you
beltran rook d5 is trapping my queen
at this point i was just like oh
so should i resign i
seriously did consider resigning right
now
and um i remember the only reason i
didn't resign
was because yeah kind of trapped my own
queen right
was because i kind of um believe in
fighting
so i want to be like okay so if he
actually picks up my queen from the
board okay that's where i'm going to
call today and go to my room eat a
bucket of ice cream and you know the
usual
so uh here
the pretty much only way i was trying to
get anything to happen like trying to
run with the queen was with b5
and i tried that because like knight a5
is also possible but what do you do
after
a3 okay so never mind whoa
sorry my siri is weird
um after knight a5
i mean what if uh white just plays c5
right what are you going to do after c5
like bishop c4 is going to come if you
touch this knight
your queen can't get out of here you
can't take that because
now bishop takes c5 and your queen is
falling
it's pretty horrible right
well yeah bishop d2 could also come up
eventually i mean not right now because
just
uh the queen runs away i would really
appreciate that
but so um
i tried with i tried b5 i tried my
chances with b5
and uh after b5 just take
i was trying to figure out how on earth
to get some pieces out of here
because i still can't touch the knights
like
if i play like nights even like let's
say knight goes back to b8
now there's bishop d2 i can't even go
back to b6 anymore
so that was the like kind of like my
ouch moment
exactly but i played bishop e6 i
realized that i am losing a peace and
i i was just trying to basically
not um lose my spirit and just try to
fight it as much as i can or at least
make it a very hard game for my
opponents to want to win it
and i did so
i managed to get this kind of position
like i'm giving my opponent
some chance to actually make mistake
instead
of just well sitting there and
expecting the loss so
in this position i did the bishop of
five just
hoping for something to happen
oh my god why did this oh chess.com
no it gave out the ending no
all right sorry i
don't know what i clicked okay
hiccups happen so queen c6 rook there
queen a5 take bishop f5 spoiler alert
yeah exactly
man all right so bishop f5 uh what do
you think it's white's best move
there are a bunch of checks to consider
so probably one of those right so which
one do you think should be
the one
um yeah i think that's true
he can't just play bishop c4
or queen d5 but i think um [ __ ] queen
d5 is even stronger because if you play
like e6
now this queen takes d6 even if you pick
that true cup
i mean this just feels really lost guys
it's like mate in what should be this
should be made it should it shouldn't
even be allowed to play like this
it's rough d7 yeah this is a bunch of
different mates
all right there we go i also did check
um
about the this kit that i played with
his um current agent well his current
rating
he right now he's 17 years old and
apparently he did make it an
international master so
yeah he was a talented kid he is
talented kid
anyways after um
aft in this position he managed to play
bishop c4
i don't know why i said managed but he
uh just went for the
bishop c4 check idea so
question for audience you see this
position
this position is horrible i know but
what do you think is you saves your best
chances of
well fighting what do you think is
black's best fighting chance
well keep in mind you can't really do
rook takes c4 because queen takes a8
that's the problem
hmm d5 guys careful
this this rook is falling with check
why the then he couldn't play the queen
two and so queen d5
yeah king effect is the best one good
job but there is
something about queen e7 i'm sure this
is possible too
yeah this is also winning just i was
thinking maybe queen d8 but just
exchange the queens and this is a piece
up and game
shouldn't be any hard to just convert
oh no you're good you're just on time
all right
so he gave this check i did the king f8
he did the queen d5 try turning to
mate me a little bit rook takes c4 is
pretty much the only move
here he started to make some mistakes
like he should have taken queen a8
and then i'd would do a c8 uh queen
would just like go back to i guess maybe
take on e6 even
i think yeah i think this was the
simplest way to win for white
just a7 and just work before
yeah the check is coming bishop v4
doesn't really serve a purpose
like i could get the king up but i mean
just recreate
and start pushing pawns this is just
lost guys
yeah so i think this was the easiest way
for
um black to lose basically
but rook c4 he didn't take it he took on
he took on c4 which started to give me
some chances of fights but i mean again
this is still pretty lost
take and now i'm just
threatening two rooks just living my
life you know
um b4 is what's i think best move
and if you try to like take on a2 just
can i just play basically anything
um yeah maybe rook p2 if take just take
on a8
yeah kind of a sad game right
so in our game he played rook back to c1
i took that he took that and
i just decided to go for the end game
and i
believe me i knew i was pretty lost i
was just hoping to get
anything out of the position and um
so yeah uh he kind of started to bring
kings i started to bring kings basically
yep we are bringing some kings
and i think bishop d4 was also a good
move
um i think the
place he made a mistake oh no we're not
there yet so he's
still going good he played bishop c3 my
whole idea was to get a b4
which is about not like a bad idea
but now i can't before there's rook d4
right and this is again super lost
so i'm
still trying to fight so
uh my question for you guys what do you
think you should do as black
what was my rating was the rating of my
opponent he was almost 2200.
he was 2176
and i was 23 50 or 60 um
i was 56 and i was 65. i think this
tournament is 56.
um be easy be careful because if you
play b4 you're kind of losing it
so we that's like the last hope yeah
hurricane four good job man
uh good job mendel so rookie four has a
kind of a interesting idea
you actually that's the thing i kind of
wanted to change the rx
because i thought if he changes the
rooks
then i could maybe throw in some tricks
with like a3 i thought i would like that
would be the best
it yeah exactly it's a sad move but
it was kind of like the desperate tribe
so now um he did this king
bishop g7 logically because if like you
start pushing now i have a3
and now um kind of a start to
feel the power of the
king and then i'll eat that pawn and
then it's actually a
pretty decent conant game for me with
lots of at least drawing chances
so he correctly saved his bishop
and i still tried to
keep it away i'm gonna go a little fast
over here
oh yeah this is actually the part he
made the mistake
so i played d5 my whole idea was
to provoke him into making any sort of
mistake
that would justify my um
well this end game and he did
he should have played the g4 first and
just like start pushing here
and um he thought that
when i played d5 i'm kind of blocking
the whole thing
so he couldn't really get in with his
king
so he kind of why am i down a bishop
oh boy you lost the fun until you got
here didn't you
so yeah i'm showing some losing games
that i survived
magic magically but so to be fair this
is a this is not like
um i mean we all have these losing games
just
we don't really think about it as much
so
anyways in this game he actually played
king d4
king d4 was the blunder the big blunder
because it gave me it gave me the chance
to actually
try and create something in this game
and i actually got this
and i finally got this d4 so
i managed to actually make a queen right
okay i think i went too fast here i'm
gonna go back a little bit
so i'm able to show you the extent of
his mistake
so not not that you guys have like a
sneak peek
on what's about to happen after king d4
you shouldn't really do the king d4 but
that was the whole idea when he played
king d3
um he was kind of getting a little
impatient and i
tried to use that that was my whole idea
because
i thought he is a kid not really good
justification but
i thought he's a kid and he
if he's playing every single move
perfect well he deserves to win
women can't do anything about it i
already messed it up
but if he's i kind of believe that he's
going to make some inaccurate moves
somewhere so i just have to try and
create the chance for him to play
inaccurately
and that's what i did so i did this d5
to give him the chance to play
inaccurately
i used to be a kid i'm 22 now not
not the kid anymore huh the kid was 12.
well i mean i mean now he's 17 but five
years ago
i was losing to a 12 12 year old if i'm
not drunk he actually
had a spongebob um pencil case
with him and that was one of the things
that in the game i kept thinking i'm
losing to keep the spongebob on the
chessboard
okay that was a that was one of the sad
moments
yeah actually king d4 is a pretty pretty
horrible move i come to the theater
king d4 because he kind of thought his
position is
too winning and he let me slip away
ergo the title of slippery dorsa
or yeah so yep
after king d4 i managed to take that and
his whole idea was to come and eat this
pawn
so that's what he did and
you got to be careful because if d4 or
not there is king d5 and now
you're losing again so that's why we
play king c4 first
and then we push that first a little bit
because even if like d4
now i think it's kind of the same idea
but i thought
maybe just f5 kind of makes it a little
faster
d3 i guess bishop f6
a3
did i have a chat with him i don't think
he wanted to have a chat with me
honestly
like the way i slipped away man i
wouldn't want to talk to myself
all right so that's another possibility
that could have happened if i played d4
first i played a3 first
and um
f5 take take not d4
pretty like it's basically the same idea
so now we got into an end game where
i'm still a piece down but there are
queens so
that kind of gives me the chance to get
some
to bring some checks and maybe give some
you know perpetual
or something
ah the poor kid i mean he he managed to
have a good chest career so far he's 17
he's international master
he's um he when i looked he was plus
2400 in rating
so he's doing good and maybe he did them
yeah that's kind of funny all right so
right now
black to move i'm going to ask you guys
a lot of questions
in this position in this end game
because so far in this end
getting to this position we kind of just
um went about it's like okay it was a
lost position now this is in a more lost
position
all right my queen is trapped we did
some stuff like that
so um let's think about how we can
actually
survive this position now yeah that's
true if you can win that h pawn that's
going to be real good
right all right so
black to move what do you think you can
do um
sato d5 that's uh pawns are going the
other way
careful with that
just check a lot yeah um
queenie one that's what i went for two
queenie one is the i thought it was the
best one
and so king d7 was the best
because if you go king f7 i could just
give a check over there and
try and pick this up whoops try and pick
this up
right maybe like a bishop of six just
take on history and
come meet me now or will come with me
now so
uh king d7 is the best idea
after kd7 what now i am going to
seriously ask you guys
every single move what now so you might
as well give me like a line or like two
moves
because this is the first
real chance uh black gets in the game
so it's important not to waste it off
so black to move what do you want to do
ah d3 staff is still way too early it's
i think
the pawn on d4 is in a better position
because kind of
your king can go hide behind it and it
feels like it's kind of blocking the
bishop
at least for right now uh what is your
idea with queen h4
a4 i don't all right
um queen a1 no so we had um
for those um if any but for those of you
who
are joining me from with our morning
chess camps
summer camps think about
what we talked about today about
centralizing
so if you guys were in the um
the class today in the camps
you should easily have that yeah queen
e4 24 is the best one
your idea with queen e4 is very simple
first of all
you got to centralize you got to take as
many squares away from your opponent as
you can
right so after queen e4 you are not
as worried about checks because
um exactly it gives you chances to deal
with the checks
it also gives you some chances to
actually like draw in more checks
okay so queen e4 um
he wins with queen f1
what do you want to do now do you want
to push d3
do you want to play like king c3 queen
d3
what do you want to do
so i have a king c3 idea
i have a pond d3 idea i'm not the
biggest fan of pawn to d3
so the thing is if you play pawn d3 then
there's like queen c1 check again
i mean i don't think it's a bad move i
just think you can delay this
also another thing to think about you
guys know about the 50
50 move rule so if you don't move any
pawns
or take anything and 50 moves then the
game is legally a draw
so i was hoping not to move pawns so
the last pawn movement would be when we
made queens
so i was kind of like hoping for that
so i don't want to really push the puns
unless i absolutely have to
so i went with king c3 i'm not saying d3
is a bad move i'm just saying d3
um i don't kind of
it feels a little weird because that
gives you a lot of chances to make
mistakes like this for example
when you kind of want the king to be on
d3 like in b3
check um guess there another check
now you got to go the other way
check um
[Music]
yeah just just feels like white is
getting a little bit
more active than i wanted to so that's
why
um d3 was not on my to-do list
i went with king c3 he did queen a1
check
so yeah i guess the only move that
is absolutely wrong is king d3 because
of queen b1
and bishop h6
right if king goes to f3 now finish one
so that's basically the only move not to
do anything
else is pretty pretty okay after queen
a1
um i chose to do the king c4 one just
because
i wanted to keep repeating the position
um so there are some questions about if
this position is a draw
yes but the problem isn't that it's a
draw
because well there's so many checks it's
a it's a draw because
uh white can't advance his position
white can't really bring in the king to
help mate white can't really use the
bishop to
help mates basically and best white is
going to get out of it is
just a bunch of checks so he gave me
another check
king c3 queen a3 king c4 just keeping my
king
right there and i'm waiting for position
repetition
so this is the second time this position
repetition has happened
right we had another queen a1 check on
move 49 we this is move
53 so that's the second repetition
so keep in mind she gave me this check
again like this
and well technically i could have
stopped the clock and
asked the arbiter for a draw right but i
kind of um
i don't know why i didn't i wasn't sure
if i was right or
not because i didn't want to risk it
i didn't want to um be wrong and give my
opponents
the extra time because that's usually
the punishment for being wrong
they add time to your opponent at least
in
in athletic u.s so i just
kind of did this king dance a little bit
longer
and we eventually just agreed on a draw
here i started giving him checks and i
finally did this d3
there check and
check and we agreed on a draw here
i could check the sheet but the problem
wasn't that it was
move repetition it was position
repetition
and those are a little bit more specific
so at this position
we kind of just agree to a draw and they
stop the clock
but let me go back to what i was talking
about so in this position
um you have to like
um like if i if it was me right now i
would mark this position
as like on my score sheet as the first
position
that happened and then when we go a
little bit farther
in this position again this is the
second position and it's also important
oh yeah i guess
i did slip this game um it's also
important that
whose move it is so right now it's black
to move it's important that when we get
to the same position it's black to move
so black to move again so yes i did have
three time repetition
and i could have claimed that but well
we got a little bit extra out of it
didn't we
so that's the first game i wanted to
show you just a second
so i go show the other one
all right this is the other game that i
wanted to show you
um this game yeah
here yep
i think everything is set
so this game was between
me i was white and um
the azerbaijani player norman khalifa
i think that's how it's pronounced she
um yeah she was
i think wim we were both around the same
rating
2160 70.
i was white this was in 2014.
so yeah 2014-15 was like kind of my big
chest jump
because i went from uh 2100
like 21.50 jumped to 2400
and then kept it around 23.50
um pre-college years yeah let's call it
that
so um
so oh yeah this is also a fun game
because this was
a scotch game and in the twitch channel
when we're doing
playing the viewers that i keep playing
scotch and then the
viewers keep saying no no more scotch
and but i always play scotch so
um i thought that was kind of funny i
think something like this
actually happened today on our twitch
channel when i was playing
yeah knight b3 and then uh knight c3
united six
queen e2 so
this is like so this positions are
basically white's idea is to get long
castle
f3 start pushing that side right
so um we did do we did um
i think yeah we had a different youtube
videos that i did for scotch but i don't
think we actually got too deep in it
like we talked more about the knight f6
scotch instead of bishop c5
and i think yeah i showed my game
against tanya and they get
some of like kasparov games i believe
those are pretty fun right
um so
okay so in this game uh
black actually went on and played a5
this was kind of like a new move for me
back then
but uh apparently carlson played it few
months
before then they before this game
and i kind of it was kind of a
sad time for me because i was like i
should have updated my opening on
weekly basis but
anyways so this game it didn't really
get to the end game parts like the
previous game
that game was it was a big slip so
uh however in this game
i really liked it because so
my my problem so let's let's start
thinking about it logically the way i
did in the game
uh this was a new move to me i was
trying to figure out what's his idea so
idea is basically to just put a4
right so if bishop a3 it's gonna i'm
gonna get
um like oops if bishop e3
i could like get this a4
e5 and i believe that was one of the
big game the games that was played in
the high level
back in the day like take i guess we'd
take that
there's a castle um
yeah i think that's about it like bishop
d4 take
uh take there or create yeah that's
something like this i i might be wrong
but i think it was a game between so
that's obviously had might have been so
um
so carson so um if you guys
find that feel free to leave it in a
comment or just hit me up and let me
know
i will also take a look to just see
if i was correct i think i am but
so that's why i just went and i played
a4
to kind of stop her a4 ideas
all right so in this position
we started to um i started to feel a
little uncomfortable when she played
knight b4
i was just like i can't play this bishop
e3 anymore
i can't really play knight d5 like none
of my moves are making sense
so the only move that made sense to me
was bishop g5 and i went for it
bishop g5 uh castle was a possibility
but um
i think it's more like castle than
um like long castle and then like there
is this like
h6 bishop h4
or maybe h4 so
that was also a possibility for whites
to cast
for black to castle earlier oops nope
that's
not looking so pleasant
well it's not like you can take it all
right let's just go back
before we lose track of the position
okay so in this position
i after bishop g5 she went for h6
now my first question for you audience
or viewers what do you want to do with
white
do you want to take that knight do you
want to well
do anything else with the bishop
basically
why do you move what do you want to do
if bishop h4 maybe think about
intermediate moves too all right i'm
seeing some e5s
i like that idea yeah so
e5 is nice i think eva is very
interesting
um bishop h4 is
the best one i went for e5 but i'll show
you
why it kind of fell apart
taking on f6 is not really desirable
because this queen takes back
newcastle castle and
this is these are like some real targets
that
black is just gonna start attacking so
black could just
play like d6 bishop out rook e8
um golf try for d5 it's it said
i don't really like it to be completely
honest
okay so um
let's just go back to potential bishop
h4
bishop h4 would have been a good idea
and the thing is bishop h4
castle castle i think what i was most
worried about was whoops rookie 8
and after rookie 8 i didn't really know
how to respond like f3
but then there's d5 this was my biggest
fear because i just
these d5s man these d5s
i mean i can't really i feel a little
paralyzed
if i play like how to defend this how to
defend against d4
it's it's very it's a very uncomfortable
position i wouldn't really want to get
into this position
um so let's say after rook e8 how else
can
i kind of protect this um
i could go for something like queen f3
and now the try and play like h3
or then later on take on f6 i guess
that's also another possibility
but it's uh to me it didn't feel so good
honestly i
didn't really want to get into those
positions it felt really uncomfortable
and
um on another note i thought e5 was
actually
the best move at the board i thought
after h6 e5
well i thought i felt like kind of a
genius like i'm
um taking the castling chance away from
you you take here i'm going to take
there you go play king of eight
take take well your king is on castle
i'm going to do long castle and i
thought this position
is a better for me and i was wrong
so this position is actually better for
black
she correctly played the queen f6 now
it is white to move what do you want to
do
and it would also be nice if you could
um
tell me if you think white is
actually better black is better what do
you think
is going on
uh also josh mayer yeah you're right d5
was a scary looking but
um f3 i mean f3 wasn't the best idea
i was when i was thinking about it i
automatically thought about f3
and then i thought if then if f3 then um
d5 and i don't really
really like like what's happening on the
board
um knights e4
that's what i thought i thought um we
could
just go about um
i did sorry i'm kind of lost on words
i'm reading the chat um i thought
i like white too because the king on g7
should be unstable
right but it's it honestly wasn't
it was so hard to attack it so for those
of you who are saying
uh king on g7 is unstable
can you also tell me why like
why do you think it is how can you
actually attack it
oh randy wells yeah i don't actually
have my own toy channel i just
stream from the club channel
so i see a lot of knight e4s
um
so i see what you're trying to say but
knight c4 has its own problems like what
if knight e4
um i just play
check now you gotta play king b1 and now
can i just play d5
yeah that's a that's a that's a big
issue
now you gotta move this knight and you
will lose this pawn
all right sorry after queen f6 what else
is the idea
uh pawn four just queen takes it
f3 is possible
so i hear you guys you guys think after
um
white is better but actually that's
unclear that's not true black is better
black's king is actually safe
i can't find a way to attack it that's
the problem if i start pushing some
pawns
it's just going to take with the rook or
even play d6 completely ignore it
because if i take it's going to be taken
with the check
and i'm losing this rook right so
um like we could try and
see look at this for a second
and then maybe i that's the problem i
don't really know what to do like if i
try and play chill king b1 just d6
next move bishop is coming out queen is
taking this it's
it's a very very uncomfortable position
for whites
um
um queen i went with dirk d2 i was
looking at queen g4
um i think when g4 is not a good idea
because just a d5
um
so i'm reading the chat i'm saying your
comments and i see your ideas but that's
the
that's like the big problem why can't
free himself well herself i can't get
my pieces out and there is no real
coordination between my pieces
right you do you see any indication that
my pieces are working together
basically not they're just a bunch of
pieces hanging around not really
working together
so yeah that was kind of my big problems
okay so
[Music]
now even if you're like atomic bishop f2
is super weak
just it's it's not
yeah it's it's a bad position i i'm i'm
hearing you
i just can't find much to do about it
i thought rook t2 was like a safe option
to protect f2
for right now and figure the rest as we
go
so right now um
what are some of the moves you would be
considering for white
g3 to prepare h4 yeah i think g3 is
reasonable
i remember the one thing that was
very uncomfortable for me to figure out
was like
all right i want something like this and
i want
one of these nights to actually whoops
one of these nights to actually be able
to get there
that's what's like really really
bothering me in the game
so um i think g3 is also very
interesting
because the bishop gets out we can try
to
do bishop g2 maybe like
go for the center
save the issue take
take
ouch
yeah this is this is bad guys
i i don't this is really bad
you um this diagonal is going to
be extremely horrifying for the rest of
the game
can't stop it can't put anything to
block it
yeah i think that was the problem with
bishop g2
that even if you play bishop even right
now it can just take and then play rook
e8
probably a little less effective because
there's like queen g4s
but you get the idea that's like white
can't really stop it
yeah exactly you can't really also leave
um so
anyways instead of g3 i played knight e4
in the game
just because i wanted to give create
some chances for mistakes
so i put the knight back in um
j3 to avoid bishop f5's too but she
didn't really need bishop f5
she just developed normally
and she played rook h4
yeah so um this is a pretty horrible
game
again i'm not really um
i don't really know how to sugarcoat it
this is really horrible
um is queen trading good for whites now
um
so for example queen e4 i
i doubt it because even if take like um
take with the king or something
i mean white's position gets a little
bit of more room to breathe
but this is still pretty um pretty
uh depressing to be completely honest
every single pawn is going to be under
attack
a4 is falling c2 is under attack there
could be some major knight d2s
it's it's really sad and also bishop
player thank you
so i just went with queen f3
and after queen f3 she just went to rick
h4
so now i was just like okay
this is a horrible position how can i um
reduce the damages that's being done to
my position
so i just want king b1 because i at
least wanted to
keep some of my queen side dignity left
right um
the problem with bishop d3 was that
if bishop d3 just takes you take back
and like it's just gonna go over k4
right away
and this is already getting again a
little too
sad ah thank you bye be
easy all right
so i went for king b1 i thought kb1 was
a safe choice
and after king b1 the this other rook
goes back to s8 well not back
doubles up on the edge file and now my
h2 is under attack
and as you can see black is not doing
anything special
all he's doing all she's doing is just
developing
normally putting pieces in decent places
that's it this doesn't really have to
come up with some magic tricks and just
play some cool tactics
it's just normal moves so
right now why to move do you think
what kind of like do you see any
two move ideas that you can try and
get some pieces out maybe
yeah i actually did go for bishop b5
surprised
surprise surprise thank you um luigi
ah careful bishop c4 is a blunder bishop
d3
just takes and takes on a4 bishop b5 i
thought was the way to go
c6 we gave a check and we
wait for mistakes king g8
now um why to move
what should you do
i'm not gonna give any hands here but um
just
maybe think how to um
bring more pieces
we were talking about bishop c4 before
queen
c3 uh hold on
if you play rookie one i'll just eat
your piece on b5
so careful
thank you kangril king lear and learning
chess
just bring in the rook you gotta keep
fighting you gotta develop
if take that's a blunder because you
just take that guy back
and like best move for black right now
is actually to go exchange queens ah
or we could actually just take over
one of these just like that yeah
[Music]
and then just work these things we're
going to eat some
one of those these two so
that is why rook d1 is the best move
because you are creating chances
for your opponent to make mistakes
so back to
this position my opponent was a strong
she wasn't a rookie and she
she was she was following my ideas so
she just one time she played d5
to block my my attack on d6 idea
now white to move what do you want to do
keep in mind your attack kind of tanked
so you gotta
think about bringing some soldiers back
home maybe
bishop v2 is interesting um bishop d3
not so much
because bishop d3 never works knight
takes and then rook takes on a4
nope not bishop d3 like bishop d3
take take
i can just take over there
yeah and this is a boar's position for
white
so not bishop d3 what else
i did have i did see some bishop e2s and
i see a bishop f1 now yeah bishop f1 is
better
um so bishop f1 is best
because you can eliminate all the other
ideas
and you are just waiting to see
what's your opponent going to do bishop
c4 would be a blender because the rook
would take it
careful yeah
set up the position for next game right
always
yep bishop f1 um
surprisingly best move for black is to
play queen g7
and after queen g7 take take
like h3 this is why uh black still has a
little bit of advantage but it's nothing
compared to
uh what it was like five moves ago
so uh in the game she actually went for
queen d6
now why to move how do you want to
try and um create anything in this game
keep in mind your position did get a bit
better
than it was like five moves ago just how
are you going
to continue to use this
i think h3 is interesting yeah
uh knight f5 just bishop takes
knight d4 knight e4 just rook takes
guys let's not give pieces for
free please rule number one don't get
free pieces
i don't know what is knight c for but
it's not here king c1 uh doesn't make
sense
just knight day to check guys i just
feel like you're shooting moves right
now
um okay yeah
you're kind of yeah okay um okay
so i see some interesting ideas um
h3 is i think the most interesting one
knight d4 is also interesting because
like let's say h3
what if um like if once black wants to
play super accurate
we could um just play something like go
back with the rook
or c5 and then allow bishop b5
those are some of the ideas
um i
i do like h3 but i think maybe knight d4
is also
kind of more interesting because if take
take you take on h2 now there i could
just
i was thinking to bring the rook back
but we could also think about rook e4
do you start using the e file
yeah those are kind of okay moves i like
those
okay um knight to e4
not necessarily because if knight e4
what if black just goes queen backs to
like e7
rook g4 bishop is protecting it guys
um e4 is possible
bf6 maybe f5
yeah now white is actually getting a
little bit um
better little compensation everything
so
i think the idea of knight d4 was also
interesting
i just played f3 because i just wanted
to
try and keep as many as my pieces and
pawns together
so um
after f3 she played f5
i don't really think f5 was the most
accurate i think maybe
uh something like
hold on let's see what's wrong with
taking if you take now i have nice e4
right
now i'm doing knight f6 so that's good
glad to
have averted
problem um
what else is there to think about if not
taking this pawn
what if so we want to do this right oops
we want to do this right
so maybe just go back and defend it
defend this square defend this pawn yeah
i think this would have been an
interesting try
all right so
um i'm still thinking what else could
have been
yeah actually i think f5 is the best
idea for black because how else are you
gonna stop knight e4
play like queen e7 i mean it's possible
but then you get rookie two
so yeah f5 was actually best idea to
stop this knight e4
whoops i double clicked and we could
think about knights d4 honestly knight
d4
take take
[Music]
take we just take that back with the
queen
and now it's a um it's a
okay position there's nothing wrong with
it it's like you can't really pinpoint
okay this is a
wrong thing that we have to fix i mean
this could be better this could be
better
but it's not it's not like immediate
danger
um i thought i did think that f5 wasn't
the most accurate i thought rkg6 was
but i that was my mistake
i did think that f5 was a little too
early
but um it wasn't true f5 is pretty on
time
yeah that was my bad sorry for confusion
grade 12
yes f5 is the most accurate and
um after f5 we could easily
try and shift these two rooks to e-file
right
maybe rookie one maybe rookie two okay
rookie one
and um
so in the game she played king f7
now can get seven wasn't the most
accurate there we go
um if you're black to move
what do you think we can do as black
i'm actually going to flip the board so
i get answers from black side
black to move what do you want to do
okay seven wider cage seven
also which rule page seven
is there any game class after this we we
kind of mix them up
so uh we'll probably go over another
game that does have um
end game minutes yeah that was a sad
game for me though
i almost slipped away but then i
couldn't
no i can no actually i have the opponent
slipped away
yeah that was taking the opponent
slipped away all right um
so not really rakesh 2 doesn't make
i don't think your cash 2 is a good idea
now can someone tell me why r2 isn't a
good idea
i saw your moves you were talking about
d4 you're talking about k7 we're going
to go look at that right after
so right now white to move oh how can we
what should whites do
why to move think about checks takes
stuff like that thank you knight takes
f5
bishop f5 now what
i guess rookie 8 is pretty given king of
7 and we just pick that guy
up right all right good job guys
so that's why rick h2 is a bad move so
rookie one
actually does have this little trick
well i had this little trick up my
sleeve basically
and that is why that is the kind of like
what we did
but what i hope to do and um
the best move for black was actually to
play like kirk h7
to save this rook because the idea was
to take
give check and ease this rook whoops eat
this rook
right now they're kind of getting away
from that
no even bishop e6 just take it doesn't
really help
actually there's queen f6 too
yeah bishop v6 doesn't really help
um pretty much the only two moves that
help
are like queen of eight and rook h7 like
if rook h7
now taking doesn't make sense because
just take back check and king up
what next
let's go a little bit back back
um
all right so rookie one queen f8 is also
interesting because queen of eight
now i still don't have this but i could
consider like something like 94
or like going to put more pressure maybe
starts rookie 5 rookie 2 to double up
yeah those are just some of the ideas
like oops not take anymore
maybe rookie five
[Music]
now if you take it now i can play like
knight d4 yeah
i i think this is going kind of better
than
compared to a few moves ago
so after rocky won she actually played
king of seven to stop this take
check in etheric so
why is the move what do you think white
should do
um it's not like a tactical it's not
like a serious
all right sorry that was a bad choice
award it's not
a very special position it's a normal
position where
you just stepped out of a worse position
and you're getting some chances to
equalize and potentially
create more chances so how can you do
that
that's the question thank you i like
doubling up the rooks good job um
queen e5 i wouldn't play it just because
queen e5
it's i think least of all you can just
take
and this guy is falling like
king six attack derek and pick that up i
wouldn't play that
i do like just simple irky two
the one thing that i absolutely dislike
about my position is this poor bishop
like
this bishop has to just have somewhere
to go right this is just gonna
get a little sad so yeah projector is
the best idea
after ricky two she started to play
inaccurately
she should have played like r7 and
or another idea is to play king g6
so these are some of the ideas but keep
in mind there is a little problem like
everything you do i still want to play
rookie five you play rook h7 and i want
to play rookie five
attacking your pawn you play king g6 i
wanna play rookie five
still putting more pressure on your pawn
now we bishop d3 finally to bring more
stuff to put pressure
maybe it goes there oh no then we can
take that
oh that's a nice tactic take take
should i take first no let's play g4
first yeah there we go
but if you take with bishop first now i
have
take take and then g4 that's
that's there we go okay
so that's some idea that i wanted to
share about this position
however this rook e5 is actually pretty
strong so you really have to be careful
about it
the one thing that uh white
could potentially count on was
this f5 idea and to just go after this
because
when i said earlier that it's not the
most accurate i wasn't
it was needed in that position but later
on through the game it's kind of
it's like a extra weight on black's
shoulders and would
take it doesn't feel right it would be
easier if it was on like
f6 right so that's kind of my point
um all right
so in the game
she played bishop d8 makes logical sense
right you want to bring the bishop
back to like you're moving this bishop
from this diagonal to this diagonal
like makes sense but it also gave me the
chance
to um get better
so wise to move what do you want to do
oh good job knight i think both knight
d4
and knight c5 are interesting
but
[Music]
i think it's knight d4 is better
definitely i also played knight t4 in
the game so good job 94 thinkers
um let me show you what knight c52 so
knight c5 is also
interesting idea but the thing is if
bishop f6
your only move is to actually play the
stacker e5
so i didn't really want to sacrifice
because i just got out of a bad position
and i really didn't want to get into
another one
so that was just my mentality like yes
you can take over there
yes you can i guess technically eat over
there too
but that my whole my biggest wait isn't
there a knight to e2
the roof takes a four there we go see
when you are playing knight c5s
um you would be when you're doing
sacrifices it feels like
you have to actually know what you're
doing because if you don't know what
you're doing then you get into
positions like this and that's not like
i don't want to get into this
yeah rookie five sacrificing the rook no
doesn't
no let's not do that night isn't
so in this position that we were looking
at
it's not about night strapped it's more
or less like if
even if like i play something like h2
why how is why it's gonna like get the
position better
knight b3 maybe but what if i just take
over here
if you take with the king i have take
and i have rook c4
so yeah those are like some of the
problems that i don't really want to
deal with
so
um if there is a choice between knight
d4
and i get to not to keep the position
complicated but to not
confuse myself or play knight c5
when i'm it's still complicated but i'm
also confusing myself and
giving my opponent chances to kind of
start poking around too i don't want to
choose that one
i want to choose the option that keeps
me sane i want to choose the safe option
so knight d4 take take
so another thing that i wanted to
mention is
knight d4 you kind of have to uh take it
with the rook
because if you don't f5 is falling or
key five is coming up if you play queen
f6 for example now rookie five
right like rooker 4 just queen e3
this is like i took over this line i'm
kind of um next move could be even
knight e6
yeah kind of nuts yeah
white has kind of just turned the table
and is better so let's go back to
what was in the game rook d4 is the best
one yeah exactly black would be way too
inactive in that position so rook d4
sacrifice is the best one
and now so wise to move what do you want
to do what do you want to do with your
queen what do you want to
try and get out of and just to mention
uh this is where i started sleeping like
i slipped away but i was sleeping back
into the net then today
um what do you say it's not a nest it's
more like a trap
but there's not trap but yeah you get
the idea like i slipped away
from the cage there we go and then i was
going back to it
slowly slowly so let's see if you guys
can find the more accurate one
oh i like the idea mark to play rookie
seven to keep it active
yeah i like that idea of um that's
excel and marker sharing
i there is something a little bit better
like so the problem with queen d1
is just you lose this h2 pawn and then
the g3 knight is kind of hanging
and then you have to play f4 and then
take it and it's like a
no thanks so
you either have to play like queen g1
and defend this that's what i did
or you can play queen b6
now if rick takes h2 you could simply
take over
there because why
the black queen is kind of busy to be
able to just take there
so now you can actually try and develop
normally a little bit i'm not saying
this is very pleasant for white i'm
saying this is
this is a fair fight both have both
chances have pretty um
good both sides have pretty good chances
um all right
i kind of just went back to g1 to defend
my
my um pawn but i
don't really like f if she would play
f4 i think this would be a kind of a
painful game because i have to go knight
h1
and then let's say c5 attacking this
and my pieces are all just like on the
first rank just
we might as well put the stroke back on
d1 right very passive exactly yeah
that's the problem with white's position
so i was kind of lucky that she didn't
play a four
and yeah i mean you do need luck in just
to actually
um get a little um
better too if you if there's no luck
then you're gonna have a hard time
winning games
honestly as good as you play
so now
my opponent played c5 which was
um sorta like
it wasn't the most accurate there we go
i'm not saying you should hope chess i'm
saying that you
do need luck but you can increase your
luck with
um trying to play tricky or
not giving up in the last like for
example the last game i showed you
my queen was basically trapped first
the 15 moves so
that's what i'm trying to teach you to
um not give up
and to just try your best to just
create opportunities for your opponent
to make mistake
yeah so c5 it's white to move um
i don't want to play rookie 7 because
just that's just the
blunder so i don't know why you guys
were
or when you guys were thinking about it
but something like rook d2
rotator is a normal move you want to
free this bishop you want to free the
swell
make it on um c4 or b5
so what's the move that you guys are
worried about if rook d2
what's the move from black that would
make you uncomfortable or for
you
um rookie 7 was not really possible
we can't go back and look um
but let's try and look at this first
so bishop d4 worries you i understand
that
bishop before worries you yep kind of
worries me too but i think bishop a4
doesn't
really worry me as much just because i
have the chance to play c3 and kick this
knight away a little
like if you were to play knight c6 now i
can just take there
or um yeah i think that's the whole idea
if you touch this bishop
your pawn f on f5 gets kind of wobbly
we don't really want that right whoops
sorry miss click um
what else can we think about
we could think about
oh bishop d4 was a good mention yeah
let's let's take a look at that for a
second
um bishop d4
let's see what can we do
well queen h1 is off the board because
just i can't just take on g3 and win
this
yeah well that's not that's not really a
question
um so
pretty much the only move we can do is
take it over there right
take take back work takes h2
um maybe knight e2
or maybe just clean back to f2
uh
so we do have to sacrifice yeah i don't
think it's like a
to me it's not a sacrifice anymore
because it's basically only move
because if queenish one we saw take take
take take even if something like c3 just
doesn't really work because this bishop
comes to e3
and if you take you're losing f1 and
then the knight runs away
um no it's
um i think this there might be some uh
definition problem
from what i understand
so it's like to me or the way i learned
it sacrifice
is something that's like good like
it's not just like only move it's about
like when you're sacrificing there is a
deeper meaning to it
there's like you are having a tactical
sum that's coming up you have positional
advantage something
but rook d4 right now is just a normal
move like it's basically your only move
so it doesn't i don't know how i don't
know if it makes sense
uh because i kind of noticed when i'm
working with them some younger
people they also keep saying let's sack
this and i'm like
man that's not a sacrifice that's
justified by queen
so i that's something i hope
clears that up so just a little
i guess terminology anyways you want to
call this sacrifice feel free to do so
but
to me that's just a basically yes it's
just a forced move
thank you uh okay let's go
back
so yes um earth d2 bishop d4
i would have taken it like no question
just like let's get that bishop off the
board
and there's something like kirk h2 now i
could play something like queen f2 and
start bringing in the bishop let's say
f4 i can just go knight oops no knight
e2
you take over there knight d4
and it feels good i like this it kind of
does feel just
it feels normal it feels like a
simple idea do you put the knight on d4
you block this pawn
you are protecting your pawn you are
creating some questionable
threats right there so
yeah um
we could do nights
i don't understand the question direct
19
f2 i guess you mean 92 yes 92 is
possible
if knight e2 what if your opponent takes
bishop a4
you don't have this knight d4 anymore
that's kind of why i wanted to queen to
be on f2
like we could play b3
but then b3
and bishop maybe d7
f4 maybe or g4 nope not g4
let's do um f4
yeah i i have ye
it's possible
it feels so
i'm not saying white is better i'm just
saying that
both both sides have a good fighting
chance
compared to the position we got in the
middle game earlier on
which was kind of a basically a horrible
position
so i'm just comparing this position to
what we had like five
maybe ten moves ago all right so
um thankfully she did not play bishop d4
and she just played
king g6 so
king g6 white to move what should you do
maybe consider some of the ideas that we
were talking about
and like some of the things that would
bother you as white in the last move and
maybe try to stop those
basically why didn't you play bishop d4
i my understanding was that
she thought she still had a better
position
because five months ago ten months ago
she did
she had a better position she had
advantage not like a winning chance
not like a winning position but she had
good advantage
so that's why i was um kind of saying
um to me this was like a clear sign that
she still thought she had advantage
when she really didn't she had chances
she had opportunities to make the
position
really confusing for me but she didn't
yes c3 is the best move mainly because
you're taking this bishop c4
id away and now the knight has to go
back so
if like knight goes to c6 or a6 like
knight a6
you just play bishop d3 and start going
after this guy
right yep okay
so um i thought
this was the first chance i got to free
my bishop and i really wanted to free
this bishop so i just went for bishop b5
bishop b5 is not a bad move but it's not
the most accurate the most accurate was
c3 um hold on c3 c4
i mean it does look scary but a piece is
a piece i'm gonna eat that piece
if you play queen takes before can i
bring my queen
uh in the game now yeah maybe queen of
two
and
then after queen f2 c3 i i understand
this this is i i understand
why this is a scary no hold on that
doesn't look great
um
take and then rook c8
no yeah you're right this is getting
dangerous i agree
so maybe c4 or c5 oops no
maybe c3 c4 let's actually take a little
bit
and think what to do taking takes back
and before
um an sc3 i agree this this is getting
really dangerous
i think the problem with bishop c4 is
just
queen comes to f4
and then attacks the rook and the bishop
so it's kind of hard to
defend it vote um
what about doubling the rooks up uh
that's possible
uh i was kind of hoping to be able to
get the queen out maybe just like queen
f2
or maybe queen where else can i go
up there
if you take on h2
now can i eat that and it's like this
maybe also
take g3
d1 you play knight c6
and take this looks very promising for
white doesn't it
um jonathan rick d4 wouldn't really work
just
because bishop just takes d4 how about
doubling the rooks
back here if c4 um why does this keep
going
back here maybe we could play um
jerk d1
am i down a piece right now no i'm up
exchange
i guess um
oh uh maybe in that position no it was
more like a rook against two bishop but
there were um sorry work against two
pieces but it
it felt like i had good um good
developments
in the position that we're just looking
at yeah um
i think this is also doable this player
d1 just keeps everything under control
if you play like rook c8 i could just
again
put that queen like that
and keep it kind of
going like this i mean it's possible i'm
not trying to justify that
uh white is like better or white is
worse i'm just showing you some possible
lines that
are good lines
so yeah it was possible to double the
rooks up
it was also possible to well just
play queen a7 i think queen a7 might
have been a little bit
more interesting because if you were to
play queen a7
um queen e3 there was not safe there is
f4
careful with little moves we don't want
to lose pieces right
i think this is the most promising line
honestly
take take on g3 or maybe knight d3
then we could just play
double the rook stop take over there
take over there attack that guy
take there take there a lot of different
takes right
[Music]
oh no there's queen g whoops
yeah this this does feel actually pretty
pretty good this is better for whites
yeah all right i think i went a little
too deep i started to lose my
myself and just go way too deep in the
positions
so yes the idea queen a7
queen a5 is quite interesting
so feel free to use some of the ideas
like that
um all right so
let's just focus on this position if
there's some confusion later on we can
come back to this move this is move 30
so if you want to come back to it and
talk about it we always can
but i kind of want to show you what else
happened in the game
so c3 was the best move
but i didn't do it because i was so
happy that i can
finally free my bishop so i freed my
bishop
and after take take back
um so let's evaluate this position
do you think white is better black is
better is about equal
what do you guys think
black much better black is a better but
i wouldn't say much
black does have advantages i agree but
there's only one move that keeps the
advantage what do you think that move is
so if you're telling me black is better
can you tell me what move would you want
to play for black
if you're saying white is better well
then we can start thinking about the
move that's
better for black how would white respond
to it
yeah you're correct um beltran queen f4
is the best move
coin f4 for black is best moved so if
queen f4
howard white wants to respond to it
for those of you who were saying white
is better
he lose the pawn on b5 where he used to
yeah that's true um axel that's that's
that's a good point but um this position
is actually
not better for white this is like a
very complicated position that's black
is doing better
yeah we're not going to resign
guys didn't you see the last game it was
a full piece down
well they still managed to survive that
so
something like rookie 3 or queen e3 are
like
the most promising ones but
the problems are kind of just like
f4 and ouch basically
um rookie three
d4 and it's again ouch
yeah i mean you could try to double the
rooks up but
even doubling them up the problem is
this just queen goes to c4 a2
so you kind of need some pieces to come
cover your king up
so that's why black is better queen f4
because the queen is coming
to whoops the queen is coming to attack
the king
so
i um my opponent didn't really um
understand that or she didn't really see
this idea so she played c4
after c4 now white is better
can you tell me why or tell me to move
um guys careful if queen takes c5 in
that position
when the queen was on f4 queen just
picked up d2
so careful on those
so what do you want to do after
c4 for white do you see any squares to
try and jump into
do you want to double the rooks up do
you want to try and get the queen out
ah carter careful c3 you give knight d3
i don't this is this is this knight on
d3 would be very painful
so queen a7 idea nice job queen 7 is
interesting
but i think right now you don't really
need queen a7 anymore
um let me ask you what piece of yours is
not working
which one of your pieces could be
relocated
i do like the idea queen 97 don't get me
wrong but you do have something stronger
yep knight e2 to control c3 and to play
knight d4 potentially
there we go knight e2 is the best one
knight e2 is the best one because well
c3 was also coming that's true
so if something like a4 now you can just
put this knight to
kind of knight d4 yeah i think knight d4
or even queen e3
because the problem was that right now
we couldn't play queen e3 because of f4
right so that is why
we finally get the chance to bring this
knight to e2
then there or there all right
let's go back a little all right after
c4
i kind of um i i realized that she wants
to play c3
also let me show you queen a7 so
if queen goes to a7
it's um i think it's
good it's it's it's interesting but it
the the move that kind of worries me
is like f4 if now you go knight e2
what if just queen e5 and starts
battering up
and then this rook is defenseless so you
would
kind of like maybe play c3
no there's a check ouch
yeah i i'm not the biggest fan of this
right now honestly
um king a2 just loses this gotta take
that
oh boy no no no no i don't i don't like
this
so how about
um i mean you could try queen d4
honestly
but queen d4
[Music]
they're also like queen e3 possibles
yeah exactly
dorset does not approve thank you um
so queen i7 c3 is not really the
strongest move
just because you take it to the knight
or is that oh hold on we didn't talk
about f4 sorry sorry my bad
c3 is possible stay three um i think you
can just
can you just play rook here
if tank then just rook e6
yeah i think this is just possible yeah
this is okay for white
like this pawn is like a big blanket
covering the king so i think that's okay
um
let's see
let's go back a little
and
[Music]
yeah um honestly after c4
knight e2 was the best move stops c3
stops d4
uh stops all these f4 ideas
and i just want to play rookie too
i just i just wanted to connect my rooks
basically
as viet vum saying i wanted to connect
my redux i wanted to
take over the file and i just i thought
that's a good move it was a okay move it
was not a bad movie but just
it wasn't the best move yes um
d4 instead of takes well you can play d4
now but now it hits rookie six right
the queen has to go away and now what do
you want to do as white
how do you want to get the pieces out
you can see that
like you are beginning to actually get
some room to breathe but it's just
not enough right
oh i chris uh chris that's true i do
want to attack but how how can you get
your pieces out
rook e5 um i think
the problem with dirk e5 is
what if just d3
yeah i think that's a big problem with
to e5
um you kind of need to to start
relocating so maybe knight e2
or knight to f1 then go to d2
i think those are the moves yeah exactly
thank you thank you grade 12. yeah i
think those are the moves that look
pretty interesting to bring in the
knight
oh queen f1 i think coin f1 doesn't work
just because of d3 again
d3 seems to be the big problem
all right um so queen d7
queen f2
this was actually the game after queen
d7 i played queen f2
and um d3 would have been
another huge pain because d3
c3 d2 oh boy
maybe take and then um shall we take
there or
drug d1 oh it hurts to look at it
uh rook d8
knight f1 oh boy
yeah yeah yeah
kind of getting a little hard to
actually slip away
um what about rook e8 to go to
to control this
oh boy take check
ouch isn't this meat to be
stoned just take a player there yeah
that's amazed to be soon
yeah that's that's a bad game it's a bad
position
let's not look at this position so
yep that that was a sad position so
um she took her cage too which is like
the second best move
best move was d3 second best was rook
takes h2
now my question for you guys what to
move
what to do
um we could consider knight f5
maybe if knight f5 king f5
do you want to give me a little bit more
specifics
um okay
so yeah let's take a look at knight five
surprisingly that is what i actually
played in the game
and if king f5 yes
g4 king g6 and just pick this guy up i
guess we can just yeah
let's just eat this yep and we win
um if
knight f5 actually best move for black
is to play d3
again and this position is actually
holding if black was to play
where to play d3 because then
um you can't really take that because
well
um queen takes and we all know how this
is going to end
just there's another check right there
and then there's another check right
there
and that should be made right
let's check take that
only where to go another check
take queen d3 or maybe queen c2 yeah
queen c2 knight d5
it's the easiest one yep checkmate
um not exactly what i wanted to
happen to me in the game so
i think black's biggest mistake in this
game
was that she didn't really use the
weakness in my king
like she didn't really try to push hard
enough to open it up
she while i did like i i tried to at
least get a 995 there i tried to get the
rookie 6 out there
but she didn't i think that was the
biggest mistake like she
almost had c4 she almost had c3 she just
never really pushed it
or she never really tried to bring like
queen or something in the game in this
side
i think that was our biggest mistake
honestly
so um if d3
happened best move for um
white was actually to play knight d4
and after knight d4
oh this is a good line i'm gonna ask you
guys to think a little about it
whoa if they're there
that that that that that
oh that's a good tactic
so can you guys think about i'm going to
actually flip the board to make it a
little easier for you
so black to move you see any tactic
there are no queen b6s right now if
you're asking about queen b6 for white
i'll get to it right after we find this
moves
so black to move where's my tactic
it's actually really beautiful
um legal tactic let's not think about
illegal moves
bishop d4 is legal your king is under
check
nope guys the ship d4 is illegal
thank you axel do you have something
more to add to your
queen takes rook idea
yeah queenie six is the most interesting
one just i would really appreciate
to um have a little bit more on it
so like what happens if work takes
anyone feels like sharing thank you
ricketts one
um if rook goes to e1 just bishop d4
right
because you can't take it i'll pick that
guy up
take that i'll take that and this is
pretty um sad position
um if queenie won i could just take that
and take on d4 right
this is also a sad position black is
winning
how about knight takes easy oops knight
takes e6
no more rick h1 so now what
see any other tactics for black
dt yep dc
if king goes to c1 there's knight d3
right that's just whoops
just knight d3 that just wins it if king
goes to anguando
um
i was just thinking about take on b2 and
then play
i was thinking about this line just take
check
take i thought that's that's okay
position for black to play
yeah i thought this is just okay
but i think uh oops nope no the king bad
king go back
i thought c3 is i mean i think c3 is
also actually possible because if b3
um we could just promote that guy
and take and then take a
check there is knight d4
so maybe let's eat that first because if
check now
there is this little mate whoa
that was scott's really deep queen c5
now just check there's a perpetual
there is this too
but
wait oh i'm under check
ha that's why i
kept thinking why can't i make this
what's this difference
all right my bad but yeah this is also
possible and this is um
um yeah i think these two are
very similar and both of them are
possible taking on b2 or c3
i think c3 creates even
more more chances
yeah i made the illegal move there we go
all right um okay let's go back back
back back back
and flip the board back to this side
all right so d3 was actually
the um best idea for black
to try and just get some pieces
out and like one last try
and taking is a bad idea it's just
because check and
we saw that mate all right let's go back
um all right so
this is the position we were talking
about knight takes f5 right
so uh in the game she actually just took
queen b5
that's the thing i don't understand like
def if i was black i think i would have
started playing d3 already
right because just like just play d3 and
then take
and like you're creating chances even if
you can't calculate
every single move you know that d3 is
um basically the best the the best
chance you got
so i think that should have happened
however
she didn't do it she just went queen b5
and um funny thing
there is a mate coming up anybody wants
to calculate
mate in six
there was a question about d3 queen b6
all right let's just look at that real
quick too
because i said we would d3 queen b6
uh this feels like
really soon coming mates just take this
if i play king here just check and queen
takes
mate if king goes the other way
just queen d1 yeah this is just mate
guys
all right so all done with b3
what about queen b5 rook f6 does look
like
the the right move right does anybody
feel like actually giving me the full
six
move mate i um well that's the way i
went about it but
this like rook f6 is better a little
faster
for kf6 king f6 queen d4
king f5
queen e4 king f6
queen e7 king g6
rookie six king f uh
king e yeah if king goes to f5 queen f6
minute if king goes to h5 queen h7 mate
did you guys do you want me to show it
on the board
so take um take
check take
check um
check and rook cheese do you get the
rook
up to e6 and then rook f6
or if he goes the other way just
queen h7 does it too yeah i mean a lot
of different moves win here
but um i kind of just went for knight e7
in the game
and knight e7 was i think the best i
mean
um just as good just took a little
longer route and then i took on
f6 and then i took the d4 and
finally like started to this is again
mate i think in
five six seven
actually yeah
um now we are actually trying
threatening luigi's sexes
well actually i'm also eating europe so
uh
in this game she played rooked right and
i just gave
check and another check and this is just
pretty mate i can just take over there
and give that check and do
check with checkmate with the rook
yeah well this was kind of a fun game
um my biggest point of showing you
my slippery or slipped games
was to try and show you that you don't
have to
have a perfect game you're allowed to
make mistakes
but as long as you fight and you try to
keep some tricks
and as long as you are not
just responding to opponent threats
and you have some of some of the ideas
that um
you're trying to put in the game like in
this game or in the last game where
well it was a piece down um there are
some
there's always a chance and
um i hope that kind of inspires you to
keep on fighting and yeah
have fun i will see you in a few days
have fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you